any opportunity to get drunk in the
morning is like a good time for me yes
the early turn up is what matter what I
actually don't drink in the morning it
goes home on a Friday evening it just
curls up and then that's you got what
today we're going to get brunch for me
brunch is like that last bit of space
during the weekend we can get that
laughs little smidge of fun
brunch is literally my favorite thing in
life
what kind of breasts you usually go to
Chinese drudge Chinese benches little
bit I haven't any friends
go guys let's go let's getting here
we're going to the San Gabriel Valley
I'm four or five actually are you and
you ever go to San Gabriel Valley no
desire or need boy there might not be AC
and I don't think there is no AC Oregon
no booze in borrow this has to be like
super awesome we're first place for
brunch huge trees pastry what is your
first impression of this I think it's
beautiful
this looks really exciting it's called
font Wan in Mandarin oh yeah yeah yeah
this rice casing is really really good
you're definitely the egg little sweet I
like the texture of the rice the rice is
a little harder took a reverse burrito
this is my child right you take it you
dip it in the soy milk mmm it's like a
churro and a funnel cake made a baby and
that's the baby beef noodle soup I
picture myself like in the winter though
sitting by a fire eating this my
favorite was that first little number
yeah it wasn't fun twines those a lot of
fun yeah
my idea of brunch is like just family
time your mom and dad and your siblings
that you don't see all week because well
you have a girlfriend resting yeah
what's next on our agenda your place my
place all right
this is a village idiot we mainly come
just to like get drinks and chat and
catch up like on the weekends but a lot
of times we'll get like the banana bread
or the pancake so I am going to share
some seasons with my friends wrong
somebody hasty dream Oh drink but it
kind of some here already how many
thought you have to drink so let's do
this
brunch is a very impromptu thing we try
and get cute but it's like a lived-in
cute yeah something that I love about
this place is that the seafood is
sustainable it's so good like a little
buttery Oh kind of just like slides on
down and now we're gonna try some of its
fish right I'm so here's how we do this
I'll get one piece all right papa
and you guys scared this I mean he's
drunk okay he's drunk yeah look at all
the wine ahead one more question have
you ever met the man of your dreams at a
brunch I have never met the man of my
dreams at a brunch
we're gonna throw in the kitchen is your
plans in there ready to mix pot curly
all right guys are going to my fav one
of my favorite spots in West Hollywood
which is a boy town in LA club Hamburger
Mary's are known for their really cool
rock shows and they're very they're
super strong drinks they're also known
for their fantastic restrooms oh you can
actually have a party of your own
like a brunch is about from me getting a
little tipsy early in the morning but I
think for the most part it's about you
know having a breakfast with your
friends enjoying yourself like I said I
always get the bot good get the job
right I try don't get too crazy because
I have a full Sunday ahead of me and I
just want to have a good time even if
everyone like um just like orange juice
with a kick in it here's guys cheers
Cheers
so we did get sliders today if I am
gonna eat I probably wouldn't eat this
whole thing by myself
you're like tiny little Bisons like each
of us kind of dip in and keep it to you
this one really doesn't melt in your
mouth
Wow and then come over the drag queens
drag queens are every day you literally
can be like hearing your favorite tunes
having your favorite cocktail hanging
out just favorite people and having one
of the best burgers
yeah thanks for Brian here I never
doubted who knew there were so many
different kinds of brunches I didn't
know that people didn't went out to have
breakfast and didn't drink you can
really eat anything for brunch so here's
the friendship and good love and good
stuff run as a brunch run good run